your lips are moving God oops I'm moving
your lips are moving then you live
online I did one of the things I said
which I said I said a few times ism I
know that you're all going to comment
below they look like a fat hannah hart
and i've heard that a lot and I'm Bray
sex I love Hannah um but you know you
know do something useful and click my
ads as well you know while you're busy
commenting a bunch of hate yeah so I
mean I'm aware of it I'm not one of
these people that's gonna read a comment
get really hurt over it like I'm I've
always been the person that I already
know what you're gonna say and I
probably know how to say it better so
I'm gonna make the joke first and take
kind of the power out of it and I mean
after eight years I've been doing this a
while so every horrible thing that could
ever be said it's been said to me and
some of them are really funny like some
of them well like well thumbs up I'm
like well I'll just respond like well
done yeah like well played that that is
some good good quality hey yeah yeah man
the harpoons is probably one of my
favorite come Oh like that's just you
know what I'm not I'm gonna block you
order TV mashes real that's good that's
at least you put some creativity and
some thought into it I appreciate it
thank you so much no but this point I
kind of did that stuff doesn't get to me
necessary yeah I can't imagine being on
the internet at 15 or 16 years old in a
video way I'm just writing fanfiction to
a colleague's a weird but like I will
talk about that but can we find some of
that no please don't it's bad it's bad
there's a lot of like x-men Rogan and
Wolverine fiction oh oh